hi everyone um welcome to the class uh I
hope the exam uh the exam went well um
and uh what is going to happen uh in the
class for the uh last three lectures is
that we are going to look at some um
Advanced topics in let's say graph uh
representation learning um and we are
going to do um a series of guest
lectures um and I'm going to talk about
today's guest lecture next so the
lecture today will be uh about geometric
graph learning or geometric deep
learning and uh kind of the the core
concept of today's lecture will be being
able to to to develop models that are
invariant uh to symmetries so kind of
that account for symmetries in the data
and are because of this able to learn
better with less data more efficiently
and so on um and uh the applications
that we are going to talk today about is
is chemistry is basically how do we
capture structure structure of molecules
using um using machine machine learning
and uh the lecture will be given by uh
mink Kaiu um he's a PhD student uh here
in the computer science department at
Stanford and actually one of the leaders
uh in this area of using uh geometric
deep learning diffusion models things
like that for uh for molecular um uh
applications so I'll hand it off to
minki
[Applause]
now yeah and uh yeah thank you Yuri for
thanks to Yuri for having me today here
to introduce uh also uh both of this
promising Direction in uh the advanced
graph representation learning and and
also I can incorporate our most recent
progress about uh uh graph generation or
geometry generation using diff
models okay yeah I think yeah U has
nicely introduced me so I'm PhD student
at Stanford at computer science working
M on intersection of generating model
and graph representation learning so the
application will mainly about like graph
generary models on molecular structure
on drug discovery on protein design
something like
this okay so this will be the outline of
uh today's lecture so first I will
introduce what is when we when we talk
about the geometric graph what we are
talking about what it is and uh what is
the key key difficulty of develop
developing machine learning models for
geometric graphs significantly different
to your pre
content for typical graph learning and
uh the second part is okay now we know
what is geometric graph we know what is
the difficulty of learning on geometric
graph then how we develop effective
model for a geometric graph so uh we
introduce some mainly two class of graph
neural network for geometric graph and
the last part is uh considering we have
already defined data we have already
developed some modern architecture uh
like a graph neuron Network how to use
this graph neuron Network to tackle real
world challenges and I will introduce
our most recent progress of geometric
def model which is capable to generate a
very very realistic uh molecular
structure okay so first part will be
geometric graph and uh maybe we can have
a very brief recap of very typical graph
so what is graph I think you have
learned it for for the whole quarter is
adjacency matrics and also a collection
of nodes the node have node feature and
they are defined by some uh connection
of the adjacency Matrix and occasionally
in the AY adjacency Matrix the AIG also
can contain some Edge feature so we want
to learn over such graph yeah very typ
thing and uh I think uh yeah this two
equation you also have learned it for
many times so how to do uh learning on
graph structure we actually use the
graph neuron Network and it mainly uh it
is mainly composed of two steps so one
step is aggregation like you currently
we are on one node and we have multiple
neighbor the neighbor will uh generate
or pred or or we want to learn some
message from the your from the
neighborhood and the neighborhood will
uh pass their message toward you you
will learn a aggregation function to
aggregate the information and after you
aggregated the information you will also
have a update function to learn how to
update current noing
body so multiple perspective of uh
understanding the traditional graph NE
Network so this is this these are these
are two most I think welln or accepted
perspective to understand a graph NE
Network One Direction is just a look at
one layer and you see oh it is one node
and there is neighbor you Pro you
repeatedly pass the message and
aggregate message and update no no B and
uh I think the computational tree has
also been Incorporated in the lecture so
when we considering multiple graph your
network you can see in current layer you
aggregate the information from your
neighbor and if you look at the the
before layer you can see your
neighborhoods in beding they act
actually aggregate the information of
their neighborhood Hood so by stacking
multiple graph neur Network actually you
just um
exponentially uh expand your perceptual
field and learn more and more feature
from the neighborhoods neighborhoods
neighborhood something like
this okay and uh before I introdu
finally before I introduce what is graph
what is um geometric graph I need I need
to also make a brief recap of uh the
graph level prediction task I know for
for graph represent ation learning I
think we usually concentrate on two kind
three kind of task one kind of one kind
is U node level prediction we want to
predict the some feature of node and um
another uh another similar application
maybe Edge prediction so predict some
feature on the edge and uh but today
maybe we first consider the uh problem
on graph level prediction so this is
very useful for especially for like a
molecular graph for small graphs so like
we we have a molecular graph and we want
to predict predict some feature or
property of this molecule so what we do
in addition to the typical message
passing neural network we call it
permutation equivariance neural network
but never mind just a typical graph neur
network uh intern between different uh
layer of graph neur Network we also have
some advanc layer like pooling and uh
yeah I think I also see the previous
syllabus I think a differentiable ping
has been also introduced before so in
addition to like just learn the learn
the embeding on node level we also can
use some pudding to pull multiple nodes
together as a super node so this kind of
formulation can significantly reduce the
number of nodes during message passing
and also it can help to enable some
message passing between multiple group
of node or in other word it is more
makes it makes more sense for molecules
because in molecules there are like a
chemical Rings or something like this
they are very predefined local structure
so this kind of ping can learn to pull
the local structure toward single
towards as represented as repres
presented as some sto single node so
abling some message passing between the
local graphs makes the uh information
transformation or message passing more
effective significantly improve many
tasks for molecular property
prediction okay
so by by last slide I just um introdu
also introduced like U mention how to
learn graph NE Network for
molecules now maybe we can have a have a
look again of uh when we do graph graph
representation learning for molecule
actually what we have as the input
so this figure is pretty typical right
so it is again so node uh different node
are labeled with like item type and they
are connected by viance Bond and the the
Edge can also be labeled with some
chemical type so something like this but
most
importantly actually we also in many
times have the 3D structure of molecules
and in many real world application we
are very interested in this kind of 3D
structure of
molecules for example when we like want
to model the uh how a molecule
is act in some solvent or in our human
body how a protein if you have some
disease there is some protein uh there
is some functional problem of your
protein and you eat a drug how the drug
will solve your problem actually they
are all effective in the 3D space we
want to model them in the 3D space so it
is
very informative and another thing is
considering for one molecule actually
even one molecule will have different 3D
structure in different temperature in
different solvent something like this
and when they they are in different
condition they will have different 3D
and then they have different property so
it never makes sense to for some
property never makes sense to input just
the the adjacent metric graph and make
some property prediction because the
property actually is more is directly
directly related with the 3D structure
instead of the 2D
structure so okay so now this is the the
theme of this lecture How We Do
representation learning on these 3D
structures and um yeah molecule is the
most exciting and U promising area of
this uh of this uh Direction so
geometric graph I mean uh it seems like
there will be some killer application of
geometric graph neural network but more
broadly there are also many other
scenario they they are also interested
in geometric graph so in addition to
small molecule there are also a little
bit larger molecule like protein DNA and
uh these three are organic structure so
for inorganic structure there are also
exciting research on Crystal and the
Catalyst and also uh those are in micro
world but in our
physical Micro World there are also
applications like Transportation the
City layout and uh vehicle and Robotics
so this this is really an exciting
area okay so now we can formally Define
what is geometric
graph from your last feedback I feel
like you are you all of you are very
familiar with what is graph so now I can
just say in addition to typical graph
so uh what's new is just every node is
additionally embedded in our ukan space
so every knowde It's associated with
some 3D
coordinates so more formally so for for
this lecture I will name the uh
traditional node no node feature like
item type as scalar feature but for the
coordinates I will name it as tensor
feature I think this is some terminology
phys used in like Physics course so uh
scalar means that they don't have
Direction they are just some some number
or some value but for tensor they are
the in addition to the to
the
uh like like in physics we
really we us make notation of tensor as
Arrow so in addition to the lens of the
arrow we also have the direction so this
is the intrinsic difference it is
directional
okay okay so before before I introduce
what is what we we are concerned about
like invent and equivalent uh maybe I
can Pro provide some very intuitive
understanding of why we want to do
environment prediction or equivalent
prediction okay so uh for geometric
graph uh let let me just take a
molecular structure as an example so
first firstly maybe let me just
introduce the supervisor learning task
this uh this slide just show supervisor
task of pre prediction of some property
of this structure
um either some functional property of of
this protein or bending Affinity of this
protein so a brief introduction of
bending Affinity so when we when we have
some disease um I think the majority of
our disease is kind of because there is
some protein there with either some
functional protein was disabled or there
is some like virus protein in our body
so when we eat a drug actually we hope
the drug to be like in this figure maybe
this is our drug so when we use a drug
the drug will combine or bend on the
protein structure if the protein is good
maybe we want to like reactivate the
function or it or it is if it is varous
uh protein maybe our hope is to
deactivate it but anyway so I just want
to see when we eat a drug the uh the
true Effectiveness is we hope they can
bend together okay but anyway they are
all like a graph level prediction when
we have a 3D structure we want to have a
have some uh prediction of the property
of this 3D structure and
um one interesting here one one
interesting thing here is when we how we
represent the 3D structure so it is the
NB 3 so when we have n node it has NB
three Matrix to represent coordinates so
every node will have coordinate so n
node have N3 Matrix to represent the
coordinates but when we do some rotation
or translation of this uh structure this
invas ret tensor definitely will change
so but no matter how it change or how it
how it rotate or how it translate it is
still the identical structure and we
really hope the the prediction should be
the same so this is the high level IDE
of what we are concerned about to
develop our neural network so it should
capture such symmetry of this physical
word okay so this one is for single
scare uh s single number prediction for
example some property so we just predict
value here we also have some other
application like um uh this one like in
in in computer vision we usually call
this kind of application as this
application I mean for example if we do
image classification we just want to
Output oh which class it is uh by
analogy when we want to do like a
segmentation of this image we will
output a very dense output of all the
pixel to to show the segment so this is
kind of similar I call it a dense dense
uh output or this prediction so for
molecular simulation um
I think it should be covered in like
high school physics so or or University
Physics so something like when we can
start from from a very unstable
structure and molecular simulation means
we really want to know what is the
stable structure of this molecule and
what we do is we have some method to uh
calculate the electric force between
different atoms and when we have this
kind of force the force can
can tell us how to move the these kind
of molecules and we move again move
again calculate the force move this
structure calculate the uh force update
this structure and finally we hope that
we can have a very stable structure
which means
the uh when we when we calculate the
force again we hopefully hopefully the
force is zero now finally so which means
we uh we get a stable structure and here
so very traditional uh simulator so it
it need a actually I think they solve
some something like shinger shinger
equation and calculate the force so
really expensive and uh here what we
want to do is like uh shinger equion to
collect many uh structure and their
corresponding Force structure and
corresponding force and we want want to
use NE Network to
learn how uh what's the force on current
structure so it is a dense prediction I
mean the output is also in three so if
we have a notes we have M three uh
dimension of forces acting on every node
every atom and move this atom so here is
another interesting symmetry right
so considering we do we do this kind of
simulation we can also rotate and
translate the in input molecular
structure and uh how should the force
move so it should rotate together right
so when we rotate a input structure the
force is mainly by like in inter
interactions so so so so the output
should rotate together and considering
translation no matter how we translate
force will stay the same so this this is
another symmetry of this kind of
task okay and uh finally is a a very
brief idea of U what we can do in most
mod machine learning especially in the
era of aigc you know so every day we can
see stable diff generat some fancy
images and also chat GPT generat some
fancy St stories so there is also this
kind of very exciting progress in graphs
so every day we see many farma company
drug company they they actually seems
like want to solve this drug development
uh problem they want they um you you
give like uh your co co virus protein
and they can generate some molecule
probably can band it on the protein and
they can also uh another promising
direction is like uh they also have some
humans antibody on this virus protein
and they can modify the antibody to make
it more effective and the develop method
to uh syn synthesize that antibody but
anyway just
uh built on the geometric deep learning
develop new gener model for this
geometries okay so here
uh I want to formally uh like chat about
the obstacle or difficulty of this area
so uh formally we can see we we can see
when we have a structure okay this
structure is here but we don't don't
know how to construct our coordinate
system we have multiple different way to
construct our coordinate system and then
the coordinates of current geometry will
be different uh um but but you know the
the atom or or the not the atom the
objective or the molecule no matter in
which coordinate system it should be the
same one or in other word if we fix the
coordinate system it can be it can be
seen as like we have a molecule
structure and we do multiple like
rotation and translation to move it all
around in our world but it is still the
same it should have the same property
something like this and
uh
however consider how we how we use
traditional graph NE Network to process
our node feature a naive way to process
the uh as I in introduced before for the
geometric graph the only additional
feature is the inass 3 coordinates so
how to process this information
coordinates a very naive way it's just
oh it is node feature right every node
has coordinates just concatenate it to
no Bing and make it as a together as a
no Bing and do message passing uh the
problem seems like it it is solved is it
really solved definitely not right so we
can translate and rotate and when we
translate and rotate the coordinate will
change and uh when the coordinate change
change after we input in into like a
traditional graph NE Network every not
embedding will change and the output
will change the prediction will change
this is definitely not what we want
so yeah this is the problem traditional
GN when when they when they see
different uh um like location or
orientation of uh identical geometry
they don't know they are the same they
say oh they are different
okay
so so what we want to do is let's let's
try to think about some no method to
make our graph neur Network can see oh
these two geometry I know they are
described differently but they should be
the same and when we make prediction the
prediction should be the
same okay and um uh the before slide is
mainly about the input space so when
input space change the Symmetry CH
rotate rotated or
translated we want to make the
prediction still the same but for the
output space there is also some symmetry
which I have mentioned before like when
we do
optimization or or simulation of the
molecular
structure when we rotate the input we
want to make the predicted Force also
rotated together but when we do
translation we hope oh the predicted
Force should stay the same so there is
also symmetry consideration of the
output space so which means uh which we
use the word equivariant so input change
output change together so yeah this is
formally named as
equivariance Okay so uh this is a formal
definition of equarius so firstly we can
abstract our graph neur Network as a
function so the function f we have the
input Space X and output space y so in
in the example here so our input space
is the molecular structure and output
space is the force or um more formly
here we only we are mainly interested in
the 3D structure so maybe you can
abstract the problem as input
coordinates and output the force so
equivariant
means when we have this kind of function
we can apply uh some transformation of
the input space we name it like row X
and uh we similarly want to make some
transformation in the output space we
name it row y so equivariance form means
for every action in The X space there is
a
corresponding uh action in the yspace
they are projective so a very Natural
Choice is they can they should be
rotated together and uh translated oh
they are not translated together okay
just think about rotation first they are
they are the rotation is input how
rotate output should rotate in exactly
the same way so this is the formal uh
introduction of equivariance yeah but
yes so translation is not the case but
still called equarian we will um present
it later so here is um some very
intuitive way to have a sense of what is
e variance
so maybe look at this first we have such
structure and we make foral prediction
okay we have all the directions and we
if we do a row so it is some
transformation or in practice it is
rotation of this system and then the
forces should rotate rotate in the same
way and here is a even more informative
way to illustrate the Equus when we we
rotate the structure the two Arrow
rotate together which indicate the force
rotate
together okay so
Beyond equivariance here we also Define
what is
invariance invariance is kind of similar
so we have a function similar function
here input an image and we input oh who
who is this famous guy okay so here uh
this one okay yeah it's a professor Le
Co right and then there is some rotation
and translation but you can still no
this is still from Professor R this is
not a mink Kai right and uh yeah this is
the formal definition of enance so still
the Space X maybe it is an image and we
do some transformation of the image and
uh then input to the function f which is
some neural network and we hope that no
matter how we apply the r x we stay the
same prediction this is
invance and um you know this is a
lecture so I need to uh present
everything in a rigorous way so formally
invariance is a special case of
equivariance
so uh by uh look look like invariant and
equivariant actually invariant is just a
special case of the equivariance mean
which means R is defined as like a never
apply any action so here means no matter
how you rotate or translate your input
uh the the output B output space
transformation is no
transformation sorry this is the bcity
though that you defined before you said
that um equivariant functions have to be
have to have a b relation between PX and
py yes uh indeed I think I realize I may
make some wrong statement of byc
yeah sorry but yeah yeah thank you you
you you are listening very carefully
yeah
so the r here is defined as no
transformation so form in variance there
is a a special case of
equivariance um but in this lecture I
will just uh uh you know I don't want to
lose the meaning of these two word so
when I mention equivariance I just
always want to see oh they change
together and when I mention invariance
later I just want to see there will be
no change of output space okay but
formally or theoretically inar is a
special case of
equal okay uh and uh here I just um have
a brief introduction of all the uh the
the task we need we will concentrate on
later for all the neural network design
so um what we talk about today is a
special
mathematically it's a special like group
in in
our in our world so it it is called
special ukian group three sc3 group se3
group means we consider the
transformation as a combination of
rotation and translation so uh a little
bit more so there are also like just a
typical ukan space E3 space so in E3
space they the additional action is uh
reflection so but in molecule when you
reflect a molecule actually the property
will change so we never consider
reflection we only consider rotation and
translation but anyway uh we I just want
to have a like a introduction of what
actions we what what Transformations we
will consider today and U the two main
task are also actually introduced
so uh where we classic problem is to
energy prediction so uh every structure
we have a potential energy so how many
potential energy it has so no matter how
you rotate or translate it should have
the same energy so it is a very typical
invariant prediction task and another
task is we want to do Force prediction
and uh as introduced before it should be
a equivalent prediction
task
to uh by the equivalent actually it
means equivalent to rotation but
invalent to translation yeah we want to
do this kind of
prediction there is some analogy in like
image domain what is invalent and
equivalent so when we do uh IM when we
do like a classification no matter how
you change stay the same but when we do
uh segmentation what we output what we
output is on every pixel coordinates or
every pixel position so the we also
change it together considering rotation
and translation so this is Ence in the
computer rant
domain okay uh a summary of uh uh all
the data and the Symmetry we need to
consider and um here is a lot of content
but maybe I can concentrate on like a
graph to make some analogy on the graph
so graph graph actually is a
permutation symmetry group so by
permutation by permutation symmetry we
can also consider two type of
prediction uh a scalar prediction and a
dense prediction okay scalar prediction
means we want to do graph level
prediction then so we predefine order of
this graph and you know in our impat or
tensor flow it is stored as a matrix
so different node they are combined
together as a
matrix but actually we can change the
order of different node they they they
are arbitr stored and when we do a graph
level prediction no matter uh what what
order is the different node we we should
do the same prediction so it means the
graph never change with different order
of the nodes so this is permutation
inent when we do graph level prediction
we are also sometimes interested in like
prediction for every node so uh node
level prediction for node level
prediction when we change the order of
the input of different node the output
should change uh accordingly so this is
uh this is this is called permutation
equivariant so they should change uh
change in the same way so I think this
is also the uh design philosophy of
graph neur Network to some perspective
the message passing you when we you when
you do message passing you never
consider the order of your neighborhood
so the message passing naturally is
permutation invariant and uh I think
this is also one of the reason of the
success of graph neur
Network okay so now let me introduce the
uh how to do graph neural network for
the this kind of uh symmetry or
symmetric data I way is okay uh we uh
also our typical graph neur Network
couldn't capture the Symmetry we can do
some data argumentation right this is
also I think used a lot in uh computer
vision when they do like
a uh classification they randomly rotate
and translate the image and uh Force the
model to learn Force the model to learn
this the same prediction here we can do
the same thing with a single data we can
just enumerate all the positions and
force the model to make the same
prediction but you know this is very
expensive very time consuming and also
not very natural and elegant and here
what we want to do is we should develop
GNN aware of symmetry just the one data
is
enough here is some uh intution
so when you when when you uh Network
design the geometric graph new network
you allow yourself to explore in the
whole learnable function space and uh
you finally your your data constrain
your model to be some Subspace but still
very large but here what we want to do
is you need to constr your your your
neural network to make it to be just the
invariant functions and you
significantly constrain the the the
function space you explore and hopefully
you can effectively learn what you
want okay so today I will introduce two
kind of graph neur Network one type is
invent graph neural network and another
type is equivalent graph oh sorry back
to the slide here just clarifying are
using the phrase geometric function to
mean the same thing as
function
geometric function uh equ function uh
not not the same so geometric graph NE
network has many many different classes
so
one we will introduce later so many
different graph Network and uh our ideal
goal is to develop very effective
geometric functions but currently we
don't we still don't have enough
knowledge to to fully capture all the
geometry information so later I will
introduce more okay environment graph NE
Network andar graph NE Network okay so
here are M two class of uh graph NE
network uh invariant means we make some
we we
only act on some invariant feature well
equ new network act also on some
directional feature I will introduce
them more later later
uh before uh before formally introduce
the neural network uh I
can uh actually I think I have
introduced all the information before
like simulation need
to uh what is molecular simulation oh
maybe another knowledge is when we do
molecular simulation I just uh uh
explain in from the Force view actually
you can also uh understand it from the
energy view so when we do molecular
simulation we actually want to find the
uh local minimum of the energy surface
so we want to find the structure of the
lowest energy and what we do is using
the using the force to optimize the
structure and the force actually can be
viewed as the gradient of energy
so negative gradient so it drive the
structure towards lower and lower energy
and finally we can get the local minimum
of the energy function and it is a
stable
structure okay yeah for we can use Force
to optimize the
structure okay so uh let's see the the
task how we train this kind of model we
have item type and we have the their
positions these 3D
coordinates and uh what we want to learn
is we want to predict energy and uh we
want to predict their force and uh the
first class model we will introduce
today they just learn how to predict
energy and uh for Force although it
should be equivalent it can naturally be
calculated by you know if energy is
learned by some neuron Network we can
just take this neuron Network calculate
the gradient of the output towards input
and this gradient can be viewed as the
force
prediction okay uh now introduce the
first class of geometric function uh
which is invariant graph neural network
uh this is shite I think has been like
many years five years yeah this this is
the first uh I think one of the first
graph neur Network on 3D structure so
it is also still the message passing
framework so let's see the equ on the L
layer uh how we update the node
embedding the node embedding is updated
at maybe just look at this equation W is
some newer Network you you can
understand and uh what we do
is when we want to the embedding of this
node we first calculate all the all the
direction uh from the neighborhood to
this node and uh this direction is input
to the new neural network WL and uh W
will output some like a controller on
this Edge which controls how the
information will propagate from this
node to this node something like this
yeah okay so formally we have WL as a
graph neur Network this graph NE Network
the input is the
direction from the neighborhood to
current node and um the output will be
some uh some like a filter acting on the
neighborhood's embedding and finally all
the embedding will be summed together as
a message aggregation simple message
aggregation just by Sum and
uh this will this will be used for
updating our current noing
Bing Okay so let let let me introduce
how we can make it in
varant yeah actually this is very
similar to our previous graph new
network so we uh the only difference is
we use some Edge feature which is the
direction to control the message and the
message just aggregated together and uh
how they achieve envirment this new
network do a very simple thing so
okay here the the input is directional
thing right the from neighbor to this
node okay I can do some very simple
thing just make this tensor to a scalar
so what they do is is called scatter
Rising so
actually when when the neural network
input is the direction they first
calculate the the the lens of this
direction so they only use the the the
this in other words only use the
distance information of current Bond and
input this Bond as the controller of the
message
passing okay yeah so from this figure to
next figure we actually do some rotation
of the molecule but no matter how we
rotate this molecule their bond distance
stay the same so considering Bond
distance stay the same
so um look at the
equ the this input is this input is
invariant distance and naturally the
output of this W is also invariant and
naturally the massage passing is
invariant and naturally everything is
invariant so very high level idea is in
one word so no matter how we rotate and
translate our current structure they
inter distance never change so the um
this kind of graph your network the high
level idea is just take the distance as
the edge feature so which never change
consider rotation and translation and
yes how can this network take account
the angle between the two BS yes uh this
is I improve word so I will introduce
later yeah so very
simple is this just equivalent to
dropping the X Matrix entirely and then
automen the feature Matrix one column
it's just the
distance um you
mean give up the coordinates tensor and
just argument The Edge feature yeah is
is it equivalent what we're doing here
exactly the same actually yeah so very
intuitive understanding is
so yeah
so yeah I I think the idea is mostly
important so maybe we can skip this kind
of details so um for for this it it's
just a single value so they make some
method called RBF to expand the distance
it is a single value to higher Dimension
and make it a more informative uh aging
B but whatever just uh some inent
feature depend on the Ed bding on the
distance
sorry
okay and uh this is so defined uh I
think considering the time
maybe skip this kind of network
architecture
yeah we can skip it um this is just the
the message passing framework we have
introduced
before so cfk and uh what what they do
is in addition to message passing uh
they first do message passing to
aggregate the information and then do
some item wise like updates of the the
aggregated information and added to the
node embedding something like this yeah
seems like should not be very
interesting
okay and
oh I have a question but feel free
to so a lot
of a lot of ules don't have one stable
structure right and they might
spontaneously summarize or or whatever
and so when you have this representation
where you say this is the coordinate of
each atom and then we're going to
minimize it and then that's going to be
the final structure kind of can be
misleading about what actually is going
on chemically and I guess I wondered if
there are alternate representations that
consider that more
explicitly like for example if you know
that a molecule can convert between two
different yes 3D structures yes can we
represent both of them simultaneously
rather than just
one you you you mean you want to have a
representation but it capture all all
the information of different stable
structure oh this would be kind of uh
difficult are you from chemistry
Department I know a little bit yeah uh I
think they they are interested in
something like uh this is why they are
interested in some generative model
because generative model can do unbiased
sampling of all these structure and uh
they do some Statistics over all the
structures but for only one
representation I think it's kind of
difficult it is always some statistical
things yeah in chemistry so
always multiple structure and do some
agregation
yeah okay yeah and uh finally we can M
make uh some make uh some prediction on
every node and uh sum them together as a
energy prediction yeah very intuitive
and uh this is the training objective so
maybe you can take a look in this model
so there is a predicted energy and we do
the mean Square arror loss of the ground
energy and we can also since this is a
graph this is a neural network we can
take some back Pro propagation to
calculate the gradient with with respect
to the input and take it as the force to
do some supervised learning on the
force okay yeah and uh for for the
improved version of dite I think I don't
want to introduce the detail but
uh
yeah the same motivation as uh the right
I forgot your name
hi you you are concerned about the
angles yeah so prev previously The Mex
passing is only conducted by taking the
distance as the uh Edge Edge feature but
but very obviously the distance is not
enough for describing the
energy so chemically energy have
multiple different components
like not only the two atem two the the
parid distance count also the angle and
torsion will make some difference to the
energy so the high level idea of dite is
okay in addition to distance I also need
to consider some other quantities and
uh they incorporate angle into the
message passing but but I don't want to
really dive into the details you can
just think okay there is some also some
angle I can somehow make them into the
Ed Bing for message party yes and the
output is still in varent because no
matter how you rotate and translate
distance and angles all stay the same we
really call them internal coordinates so
they never
change however all this kind of method
are relied on
like uh scalarization so we reduce the
coordinance into angles and distance is
the sufficient description of the
geometry actually definitely not so
consider these two molecular structure
so they have identical distance and
identical angle so when we do that kind
of that kind of environment prediction
um for inent prediction is fine so we
can ensure the prediction is inent but
but as you can see some information is
loosed in this kind of structure so this
two our prediction will also be the same
this is wrong the invariant is a little
bit over invariant so but consider if we
can truly incorporate some direction or
tensor into the framework like when we
add some more description of these two
node with their like middle direction of
their two bonds they can be
distinguished now so with some tensor
feature so the next large class of
geometric GN is how to incorporate this
kind of tensor feature and uh I call it
equal I will call it equivalent graph
new network because this kind of
directional tensor will be equivalent
with the input coordinates so it always
store some equivalent feature during
message
passing okay so another motivation for
now why we we are not satisfied just
with envirment graph neur Network so we
have a we have Cass of all the neural
network can fully capture all the
geometric information and what we want
is the orange part but now when we
constr our when we constrain our to only
environment features like distance and
angles actually we constrain ourself to
really a Subspace and maybe we couldn't
find the all the optimal solution or in
in your network we usually say we want
to Define our function as some Universal
approximation but here we constrain our
function too much we want to release
some space of our neural
network okay so uh high level idea of uh
the uh recent progress of uh urrent GN
it it's called called a pain yeah kind
of
interesting uh yeah the this new network
uh some part is same but some part is
different so the the same part is we
still have like for every for every Edge
feature we will have a matrix and the
Matrix control how message is passed
through this Bond and
uh this filter or this with Matrix W is
still conditional on just a
distance but what is different is for
for every node now we not only have just
a regular noing Bing as you learned
before and as I introduced before the uh
invariant no bding we also for every
node after every layer we give them an
additional Vector feature the vector
feature will change to together with the
input so just a quick uh introduction of
uh what we do for the scalar feature and
the vector feature so the scalar feature
will be initial an atom embedding or no
embedding so it is very typical input
one heart and learn some
embedding and the vector feature we will
begin with zero so set them all with as
zero they are updated with some residual
updates so in every layer we will learn
some updates of uh both s and V both the
envirment feature and equalent feature
and uh this two feature will be used to
updated in the rest net View Rest net
fashion so just a plus but whatever so
now we are interested in how in each
layer we update the S and V the no
scalar embedding and tensor embedding by
Delta s and Delta V so here is the
equation but I will introduce more
details
later so okay so first I see how we
upate the no scalar noing
B ex uh I will see exactly the the same
as uh shet so the environment neur
Network so maybe uh let let me still
introduce this slide
so yeah distance in input to a matrix as
filter and filter filter can can be used
by can be used for like fire I learn
some uh uh feature of current node of
neighborhood node and the neighborhood
node embeding combined with the edge
filter W they combine together as a
message in that Bond and uh for that
note all the messages FS multiply with
WS combine together as the message and
the aggregated message everything here
is inir because only depends on distance
still the
same but here we have something
different as the vector tensor
so how we update the vector T Vector
feature so we input the distance and we
have have the output with Matrix to
control the message passing and
similarly we also for all the
neighborhood we use neural network FS to
learn some message from that node
however for the message passing it is
not only two scatter multiplied two two
scatter tensor multiplied after the
multiplication they also multiply with
the radius
Direction uh not radius direction or the
uh neighborhood to current node
Direction so it is Multiplied with this
tensor and
U our V our tensor ban will be updated
by a weighted sum of all the relative
Direction so relative direction from
neighborhood to current node so think
about the thing um when we do a
translation when we do a do a rotation
of the molecule structure like from this
this structure to this
structure the relative direction will
change together so here the relative
direction is like this direction but
after you rotate it will change together
and all the relative direction will
change together so naturally it a weed
sum of all the relative direction will
change together so I call it a rotation
equivalent feature so this is
the way to learn the equivalent
feature and
U what I just introduced it's a single
layer for updating the uh inent no
embeding and ENT node embedding and by
stacking multiple layer we can we can
have the uh have the output to be still
equivalent to the input so which means
when we do a rotation of the structure
the output force will rotate together
and uh same as what I have introduced
before and also the tensor feature
helped to capture more information in
our before example to to show that
distance and angle is not
enough okay yeah this is pin and uh yeah
considering the time maybe skip this
summary and uh begin to introduce the
most recent progress of fancy demos of
the geometry gener model yeah there are
re really many many exciting progress of
protein design in Farmer company and uh
generator bom medicine is
uh actually the
the same the same founder I think of Mna
so they open another company of AI
motivated drug Discovery company so all
this kind of task is mod than diffuser
model okay so today the the uh problem I
would like to concentrate so we need to
have a task to concentrate on to
introduce our model so what what I do is
um give the molecular graph we want to
predict it a 3D structure and uh yeah as
as this front just say so every molecule
will have different multiple different
structure so naturally this is not a
prediction task prediction task means
one one Ming but actually it has
multiple stable structure so naturally
this is a um generation task and U
physics
there is some distribution of this uh 3D
structure it's a bman
distribution given some temperature but
never mind so just want to see there is
a
distribution moleular gra has to be 2D
can you have that cross
BX says that the molecular graph is 2D
2D why does it have to be
2D why is why does it have to be 2D can
have like cross over B cross over B like
the the gra on the left that's 2D like
for example to draw two bonds that
are overlapping you're looking at from a
perspective that be that would
3D 3D
gra
uh you mean
3D Oh you mean def bond to have the
direction right so I mean the Bap so
have to be a 2d
at
second this specific graphic is Tod to
be
representation oh I see oh for for this
task we what we want to do is given 2D
we want to generate
3D uh but yeah graph can be represented
represented in 3D that's fine
when you say 2D graft you really just
mean
an yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah there we go
sorry yeah yeah uh I think yeah sorry
sorry uh I think I still miss some
detail yeah molecule you already have
like three level of representation uh
the the most naive way is to actually
they they have a sequence representation
of molecule just some item and uh some
it is called smiles and uh yeah so
application on 1D representation is very
natural all thep task can apply on it
and then graph new network and everyone
work on I us call 2D so ATS means
adjacency metrics and no feature and now
we concentrate on 3D but actually it is
still graph repres representation yes so
every node we have an additional like um
coordinate for every
node but the the the the task is 3D
generation that's all what I want to see
for this slide
yeah yeah and uh similar
to um s similar to The Learning similar
to the representation learning for 3D
graph which need to be like capture some
invariant and equant here is the same so
uh for the gener model also want to
incorporate some uh some equence into
the model and uh yeah I know like if I
introduce the full information of Def
model it will be two time consuming so I
deleted something but formally what we
are concerned about developing gener
model for 3D is gener model essentially
want to estimate the likelihood of data
and uh do some something like something
like a maximum likelihood train and here
you you you can think about likelihood
is probability right so no matter how
you rotate and translate your data or
your 3D data when you when you input it
into a gener model it will tell it will
tell you a likelihood so the likelihood
should never change considering the
rotation and translation so this is
theoretically the consideration of
developing geometric gener model but
here I just
yeah so skip some technical detail of
gener model and some very intuitive
understanding of diff model so diff
model means when we have this kind of
image we will we will add noise on the
image to destroy it to different level
and uh like in here our data we ually
denote data as x0 we will have multiple
different level of noise to destroy
until random caution and what we want to
learn is for every time
step we we first perturb the data and it
will be a noisy data and we we want to
we want our model we will input XT into
our model and hope our model can predict
what is XT minus one so how to
denoise similar to here so we we
predefine how to perturb or how to
diffuse the data and what we learn is
the reverse Direction how to denoise so
diffuse model the general idea is predin
diffusion process and learn a model to
generate by the noising so this is a
high level
idea and uh very brief introduction of
diffus model there are many many fancy
mathematics for def model but here I I
think I summarize the least requirement
of the def model so you can think about
every time we just randomly sample
random noise oh still made made some
Miss some information the random noise
is sampled from normal distribution so
mean zero and variance as unit variance
and we destroy the data by uh to to the
tstep diffusion data by mply Mt and uh
plus
Sigma Sigma with the the the noise and
uh the high level idea here is in the
first step in the first few step uh by
step I mean the the T so when T is very
low we hope that the MU T is nearly one
so mu0 is one and we hope we we not we
hope we set we Define yeah and we Define
Sigma zero as zero so which means we
never destroy the data and with very low
time temp step T we just destroy the
data a little bit and uh what we Define
for the final step
is I think shouldn't be one it shouldn't
be capital T sorry
uh yeah so mu capital t is near zero and
the MU capital t is nearly one which
means just a totally dist the data into
random noise yeah you multiply a zero
and destroy the data and make it this is
one so make it just a random noise and
uh what we want to do is every time we
we give give us a data we perur the data
to some time step and we put this noisy
data and the time step into the into the
neural network and we hope our neural
network learns how to to to predict the
noise vector and if if this this can be
learned very
precisely you you can know here if we
know XT and we know the
Epsilon and Mt and sigma T are are
defined by by by Earth so we always know
this kind of parameter so we can recover
the clean data so this this is kind this
is the high level idea of diffusion and
uh yeah this is is also the sampling
procedure so we just always sample a
very noisy data from go noise and we
repeatedly from time stamp capital T to
time stamp capital Z repeatedly input
model predict the noise vector and you
subtract the noise Vector you can
progressively denoise the data and
hopefully recover a very realistic data
so yeah I think most of you have played
with like stable diffusion give some
prompt and generate really fancy image
so really impressive progress of this
field so yeah this is this is also uh
from Stanford so stepan manman another
professor working on General
model and uh yeah this is some
uh really fancy
G4 the process and the reverse denoting
process they recently formulated this as
a
stochastic uh differentiable equii
something like this
yeah yeah and this is our paper
so we extend the idea of geometric
learning of diff model from typical
image to also the geometry and U yeah
very happy it is top 50 most seted paper
in 2022 yeah so I just want to highlight
it's a promising Direction and exciting
research field and uh yeah this is what
we do
so um for given a data c0 exactly the
same idea so add a noise to destroy it
and uh learn the reverse process to
progressively dening to generate data
however when you have a look uh I I want
to introduce the work by very intuitive
way so I just skip all the mass in the
paper so when you just have obser
observation of this figure you will feel
like oh actually this is progressively
denoted by the noise Vector actually
this is kind of a similar to the
molecular simulation so molecular
simulation when we do molecular
simulation we always have either a
classic like a shorting or solver or
graph neur Network it will tell you
what's the force and the the force will
be used to optimize the structure and
here what you do is you always have a
also have a structure you input to the
new network and it's tell you a denoting
Direction so you you follow this
denoting direction to up up your
structure so this is kind of similar
right output Den Matrix and optimize
your structure and what the Insight of
this observation is similar to force
maybe we also need to give the new
network the power of capture the
equivalance so how to denot the denoting
Vector should also be equivalent with
the input structure no matter how you
rotate or rotate your structure the
denot direction should rotate together
so this gives us the
um the motivation to impose this
inductive bias into our model and what
we do is parameterizing the denoting
network with equ graph new network and
uh yeah and uh just uh this kind of
thing this is an uh visualization from
my paper and it generate although there
is some like the the ring is not on
Surface right but still fine still learn
something and it gives the community the
first verion of how to how to define def
model for
geometries and uh yeah I suppose maybe
some of you are familiar with diffusion
considering if you are familiar maybe
you think this is trival and I can speak
a little bit more so uh for diffing
process as you can look diffing process
actually is a if if you couldn't
understand never man so it's not
important so diffusion process Define
Mark process of generating from pray
prayer distribution towards the data
distribution and by we have a PRI
distribution P of CT and we have all the
mark of kernels and we multiply them
together we can and do some integral of
all the hidden latent Vector we can have
a probability of the c0 so I just want
to see by Def model we can define a
probability of P of data or likelihood
of data and uh imp uh impos imposing
equence into the neural network uh here
the motivation seems like some
observation but the true motivation for
my paper is I need to make the
likelihood estimation to be inent to the
translation so no matter how you rotate
or translate your structure def model
can be able to calculate some likelihood
and this model can naturally make the
likelihood invent to rotation and
translation so this is some theoretical
motivation and um yeah if you are
interested you can see the paper but
here maybe too heavy to introduce all
the mass behind the this
model uh
let me click on the figure this is the
most excite most recent exciting
progress of diff model so this is now
very very realist realistic realistic
problem now so we have some protein in
our body so here is also we have some
scan fold protein in our body and we
really want to make it more stable or
want to make some antibody to bandism or
something like this and uh these two
figure show that we can already use
diffusion to generate
some in in generate some promising drug
or antibody for some disease also there
still need some clinical tra to verify
the effectiveness but yeah already
already pretty promising
now okay I think yeah it's also the time
now so maybe just uh one or two minute
to introduce some future Direction uh
also what I'm working on what I'm
working on recently is if we have a poet
like like if we have some uh L behaved
protein how to design small drug for
this protein Target and also this is
antibody design so we already know human
can generate some antibody for uh for
some antigen and we want to do some
mutation meaningful mutation on the
antibody to make it more effective and
we can synthesize
it okay yeah this slide is from many
people and uh I think that link are also
meaningful resources if you want to
learn a little bit more so U is mainly
for General graph and test is in uh PhD
in physics I think and G is my previous
uh Master adviser we worked together for
the uh G paper and also stepan y now
professor at kch now and the r is uh
anyway Pro uh biologist biology
Professor so all kind of resources and
uh that's all sorry for one additional
minute
yeah and
uh thank you thank
you